معنا من غازي عنتاب الدكتور كرم قنا رئيس
الهلال الاحمر التركي دكتور كرم اهلا بك
مع ارتفاع عدد ضحايا الزلزالي الاكثر من
اربعه وعشرين الف وعشرات الالاف من
المصابين والمنكوبين كذلك نريد ان نسمع من
كيف تسير
مجهودات
الاغاثه للهلال الاحمر التركي
جزيلا على الاستضافه
[تصفيق]
تكرار السؤال سالتك عن سير مجهوداتكم
الاغاثيه مع وصول اعداد المصابين
والمنكوبين والتي تقدر بعشرات الالاف
بالنسبه الى الهلال الاحمر التركي
ولديه فرق عمل ولديه متطوعون وهو موجود
وهم موجودون في الميدان على الارض في 48
مدينه
بما يقارب
سته الاف شخص من العاملين والمتطوعين نحن
نعمل على توفير المساعدات الغذائيه
والدعم
لاثنين فاصله سته مليون شخص كل يوم
في 400 نقطه مختلفه وموقع مختلف لقد قمنا
بانشاء مراكز عمليات خاصه بنا قمنا بتوزيع
المطابخ النقاله او الجوال الخاصه بنا
وقمنا
بانشائي مطابخ صناعيه
توفر الوجبات الغذائيه على نطاق واسع
وبالتالي بالنسبه للمساعدات الغذائيه لا
مشكله اطلاقا كذلك فان هيات الاغاثه
التركيه
وجمعيه الهلال الاحمر التركي كذلك قامت
بتوزيع ما يقارب الفي خ في المناطق
المنكوبه
كذلك فان جمعيه الهلال الاحمر التركي
تقوم بانتاج يومي يصل الى خمسه الاف
خيمه كل يوم من المصانع التي تتعامل معها
خلال ذلك ايضا
نقوم بعمليه البحث والانقاذ والاغاثه
ونحظى بدعم ومسانده من الجمعيات الدوليه
هناك الكثير من الفرق الاجنبيه للبحث
والانقاذ من الهلال الاحمر ومن الصليب
الاحمر التي
هرعت الى المنطقه من اجل مساعده المنكوبين
هل لديكم ما تحتاجون من مساعدات من هذه
الهيئات الدوليه ام هناك نقص ما الذي
تحتاجونه بالضبط في هذه الاونه
بالنسبه الى نقص الاساسي فهو يتعلق
بالمساكن والملاجئ واتحدث هنا عن الملاجئ
الدائمه او نصف الدائمه التي هي مصنوعه من
الخشب والفولاذ وغيرها هي في نقص ونحن
نوفر الاف الخيام بالتعاون مع هيئه غذاء
تركيا ولكننا بحاجه الى المزيد من الخيام
نحن بحاجه ايضا الى مواد ورزعم صحيه
بالاضافه الى الرسم غير غذائيه للضحايا
نحن ايضا بحاجه الى دعم ماديا نقدي يوفر
للضحايا ايضا
احتياجات اذا عديده لكن ماذا عن المساعدات
التي قدمت بالفعل ما تقييمكم لحجم
المساعدات الدوليه التي قدمت لكم
اذا تحدثنا عن المجموعه اليومي فنحن نتحدث
عن تزايد وارتفاع في هذا الدعم والمساعدات
الاجنبيه هناك الكثير من طائرات الشحن
بالاضافه الى الشاحنات التي توصل
المساعدات مساعدات على الاغاثه كذلك يصل
اشخاص من فرق البحث والانقاذ والمساعده
والاغاثه كل ذلك يحصل بالتعاون مع وزاره
الخارجيه التركيه ونرى ان جمعيات الهلال
الاحمر التركيه تقوم بتوزيع هذا الموارد
البشريه الى المناطق
المتضرره والمنكوبه ان فرق البحث والانقاذ
وانشطه البحث والانقاذ لم تكتمل بعد او لم
تنهي عملها بنهايه الاسبوع المقبل
سوف ننتقل المرحله التاليه وهي مرحله
التعافي ان صح القول وبالتالي
نبدا حينذاك ببنائي المساكن والملاجئ
ادائم ونصف الدائمه ونحن بحاجه الى توفير
الرعايه صحيه الدعم الاجتماعي والنفسي
بالاضافه الى مياه الصرف الصحيه المياه
الصالحه للشرب والمساعدات الغذائيه الى ما
هنالك اذا هدفنا هو ان نصل الى من لا يقل
عن مليونين شخص طيب دكتور قرن تحدثت عن ان
عمليات البحث والانقاذ ما تزال جاريه حتى
الان هل لديكم تقديرات ارقام تقريبيه
لاعداد العالقين تحت الانقاض حتى الان
ويجري البحث عنهم
الحقيقه نحن لا نزال نصلي وندعو
اذا ما قارنا
اثار القنبله الذريه فيه روشيما يمكننا ان
نقول ان ما حصل هنا
يتخطاها الفي ضعف نحن
نخصص كافه جهودنا لمعالجه الوضع تخيلوا ان
ما حصل فيه هيروشيما
حصل 2000 مره اكثر هنا طبعا بالنسبه الى
عمليات البحث والانقاذ لم تنتهي نحن لم
نقم بالبحث تحت كافه الانقاض وكافه
المباني المهدمه لكن فرق البحث والانقاذ
لا تدخر وسعا تستخدم كافه التجهيزات
والمعدات والتقنيات
المتاحه لها والتي توفر لها من اجل ايجاد
ناجين تحت الانقاض نحن
نقدر ان العدد سوف يكون الى تزايد شكرا
لكم
رئيس الهلال الاحمر التركي هناك